why don't you this book actually the
real truth is it was in a stack of books
sent to me by the book editor at O
Magazine Leigh Hebert and so she sends
me books all the time to read and it was
in a stack of about five or six books
and in the stack it was the one with the
boldest cover and the name that I was
drawn to is behold the dreamers so
because of the cover I know they say you
can't judge a book by cover but I like
the cover it was it stood out and I love
the title behold the dreamers so I
wanted to know what is that about that's
how I chose it to read and then after I
started read and then after I started
reading and I thought whoa this is as
good as a cover so I'm excited that
everybody else gets to indulge in the
luxury of the story for the first time
[Music]
I like reading all kinds of fiction
historical fiction particularly I'm
drawn to but when I find a story that is
as modern and feels like it could have
happened today or certainly yesterday or
in these times that has all the dynamics
heart and soul of family connection what
it really means to know what home is it
has drama
it has great antagonists and
protagonists and people that you're
rooting for and people that you're like
why are they still in the story it has
all the elements for a read that allows
you to take your mind and thoughts and
your idea of what it means to be a
certain kind of person in the world
someplace else
well first of all I like many of you I
could not pronounce the author's name
her name is M below way you just way so
what struck me was what what is that
name and when I called her up to tell
her about the book club and that I was
choosing this book and that I had been
so engaged in this story her reaction
and her story about how she came to
write the book just was more than I
could have imagined so way to hear that
story it's such a great story
[Music]